[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about our
thoughts on Peter Thiel Peter Thiel is a
very interesting man
he provided the co-founder of PayPal
co-founder Palantir provided the first
outside investment into Facebook he has
invested into so many different
companies including seasteading which is
building cities in the ocean near the
coasts also into vegan pet food startup
wild earth he is a proponent of
nationalism a supporter of Donald Trump
so he's very skeptical of globalism in
many ways he has touted around the Bay
Area monoculture slogan which comparing
it to North Korea in very interesting
ways he's the author of zero to one
which is one of the greatest businesses
books of all time and so this is a very
long intro about Peter Thiel but it's
super fasting all the different work
he's done so let's jump into some of the
things that we're gonna talk about and
I'm gonna flip over time'
to give us better perspective on time so
let's do this so let's talk about some
of the first so he definitely had a
major rocket forth in PayPal so this
photo here kind of gives you it's it's
it's a little hard to see but it's the
photo of the PayPal mafia and it's this
group of gents that kind of put together
the basic infrastructure for being able
to send payments electronically and
there were so many other people working
on this and now
PayPal's also has all these other
competitors in the transaction space but
this was a big deal for making internet
payments was PayPal and then through
this exit he was able to do things like
then fund be Facebook's first outside
investor and then also fund his own
investments into these other companies
and then into Palantir as well and
Palantir is a very interesting company
because I don't think we talked enough
about
what data fusion software is but that's
exactly what Palantir does is they do
data fusion so you see here what I'm
highlighting on their website they talk
about scale speed and agility building
products that make people better at
their most important work and so back in
infrastructure for integrating managing
and securing data of any kind analytical
applications interact smooth with data
and for any data problem and so some of
the big things here that are it's very
difficult to find this sort of stuff you
know mentioned but but it's it's it's
difficult it's yeah yeah it's difficult
to find this sort of stuff mentioned
because because a lot of what Palantir
does is done for data fusion for
governmental agencies and that is used
by places like the NSA places like your
San Francisco Police Department in New
Orleans Police Department hago New York
Police Department etc and the journal
idea is this predictive Crime analytics
so and that's one of many things I know
I know very little about Palantir but
what I can tell you is that it's very
difficult to find information about
pounds here and rightfully so and I
think I have friends that work at
Palantir and it's been very difficult
for me to talk them about what they do
and they kind of very much so make it
difficult for me to like understand
better what is going on but law
enforcement agencies this is this kind
of it's a big it's a big deal and I
could spend a whole frickin thoughts on
episode talking about just pounds here
but just to understand it's like it's
like taking all of this crime analytics
of let's say the Chicago area and seeing
that the individual in the Chicago area
has a certain criminal history they're
geo located in a certain location
they're posting these certain things on
their social media accounts they're in
this location next to this other person
that they've previously committed a
crime near or around so that way police
can come and make an intervention before
people get hurt so before people get
hurt this is a big deal but it's also
kind of a little bit big brother' esque
and so the general idea with Palantir is
that if you mix together some data
fusion of this big brother' esque stuff
with something like
like Boston dynamics in terms of those
amazingly compatible robots that can do
so much different work right now
backflips and stuff super interesting
and then throw a little rifle or pistol
onto them and have millions of them
there is some sort of a dystopian image
they're not saying that that is what's
happening I'm just saying that it's
important to talk about these things at
least so that we can epically steer away
from them so anyway think about that
just for food-for-thought pounds here's
an interesting company hopefully saving
lives making people's jobs easier
through the structure of data but at the
same time let's talk about some of the
ethics the Big Brother esque stuff let's
figure some of that stuff out so that's
a little bit about you know about
Palantir then something else that's
really interesting is the teal
fellowship I thought I mentioned that
maybe I maybe I didn't as we were
talking but the teal fellowship really
takes a turn ative approach to education
so rather than seeing education as just
a you you go until you're 18 and then
when you're 18 you go to college for
four years and then you do that and
that's that's how it goes that's your
process Peter teal is talking about how
do we just flip the whole system on its
head how do we unleash the creativity
and lock the creativity out of the youth
that younger ages and that sort of
creativity has the potential those ideas
have the potential to impact millions
and billions of people and not and and
not go through the collegiate system
which is in many ways good but in many
ways also cancerous and so this is a
really fresh take on it and so boom just
like that $100,000 two years going to
execute this idea go and get it done
that's how beuter and was one of the
many people that Peter Thiel has taken
out and unleashed and he's the founder
of aetherium so he's been right he's
made some really good calls in this
sense and I think he does a pretty good
job at explaining here why a different
path for everyone
freedom to get stuff done our network is
yours you know these are pretty
important pillars and so I think he also
writes about this quite a bit in 0 to 1
if you guys haven't seen zero to one yet
or reddit I highly recommend reading
zero to one this is
you know the book cover looks like notes
on startups or how to build the future
and we talk about building the future
all the time on here on the show and so
the run of the big you know this was a
lot of this was based on teals Stanford
University class on startups that he was
teaching back in the spring of 2012 but
what's really amazing about this book in
my opinion is that it talks about how to
both unlock your fullest potential
creativity and don't just do it in terms
of don't become the tenth restaurant in
your tiny little neighborhood because
there's ten other restaurants just in
your neighborhood and there's tons of
competition
don't enter fields that have lots of
competition but rather enter fields that
don't have any competition make brand
new fields start a monopoly and that is
the way to really rocket yourself
forward into the world build something
of value and find those creative
potentials and also when you go from
zero to one that means you take
something that didn't have an idea and a
one is when you've made that idea into
the world and then when you go one too
many is when you take an idea that
somebody brought from zero to one and
then you take that one and distribute it
to many people like globalization and so
Peter is really keen on the zero to one
side of things but also the
globalization parts crucial on our show
yesterday with David Eagleman our live
event we were talking about the
genealogy of ideas as in ideas have been
around for so damn long and we're
constantly bending breaking blending
these ideas over time so that's a bit
about 0 to 1 as well just really
interesting genius there I really like
that a lot and then I want to talk about
some of his investments by as we go this
one's really interesting this it's
called the seasteading Institute I'm a
big fan of this myself the general idea
is that you can take and and build
colonies or or civilization inside of
the oceans on near the coast and so when
you take a look at some of these designs
I mean they're very beautiful the idea
is that you can have a sustainable
community living there and that means
solar panels of the gardens you got to
figure out a way to desalinate the
you got to figure out or it's so
beautiful we've seen images of beds that
have been underneath of the water in
glass compartments so you're literally
laying and you see the fish swimming
volume stuff so beautiful at night
there's no light pollution so you get
this beautiful all the light from the
galaxy and the universe just shining on
your eyes so you know all these
different examples of what these hold
these like seasteading colonies could
look like are just so magnificently
interesting and diverse and and
fascinating I think it's important to
explore this as humanity to see what
this would also be like so another one
is wild earth which is a vegan pet food
company shout out to Ryan Bethencourt
Ron should get our friends that started
that and he recently invested into that
just like I think two weeks ago or so
which is huge and it's interesting how
has you know how his investments are
diversified in that sense now on the way
out I want to mention sort of this idea
of the Bay Area monoculture I'm gonna
pull up you know just the Google search
here is Bay Area monoculture and you
know there's calm like Peter Thiel said
he's ditching Silicon Valley and going
to LA he's he's made it very clear that
that Silicon Valley is an intolerant
place and that that's funny that there's
this link Palantir knows everything
about you by Bloomberg at the bottom but
just in general this idea that Silicon
Valley's become a monoculture I've been
trying to explain this for a while and I
just we actually just did it on our last
episode with Alexandria
Acacio Cortes as we mentioned how in
Nebraska there is a conservative
monoculture that's going on at these
live events and stuff and so it's very
difficult to be a liberal or progressive
because it's a ninety nine to one you're
constantly getting shut out whereas in
the Bay Area it's a hyper liberal and
socialist monoculture so it's very
difficult for someone that's a
conservative to voice their opinion
because they immediately get shut out so
so basically what happened was Peter
Thiel supported Donald Trump and
everybody was like what how is that
possible no way and Peter Thiel's gay as
well which is very interesting and so he
chose to support Donald Trump people
freaked out about that and then he
understood better about this whole idea
of intolerance that there's intolerance
ideas that you know the day after Donald
Trump was elected we went out into the
streets and we started asking random
people do you think Trump possesses any
good characteristics we were honestly
trying to just get really interesting
thoughts from people and the general
idea that people were calling him Hitler
and all this other kind of stuff and
then there were some people that were
saying that no it's like it's good this
is really interesting to have somebody
in business to take over the position so
a president so just as general notion
that it is important to not have a
monoculture that when it's a 99 to one
you're literally cutting throttling
people's ability to speak and have these
Copernicus moments potentially again
Copernicus was the one that said that
the earth does not at the center of the
universe but rather the earth orbits
just around the star the star doesn't
orbit the earth and so again everybody
thought against that but he was right
I'm not saying that Peter Thiel is right
in this sense but I'm saying that it's
important to not shut people out because
they could be right in these Copernicus
moments so much these blacksheep moments
so the globalization is currently a
hot-button topic that Peter Thiel is
currently teaching as well and I want to
showcase this which is the fact that
he's actually teaching a course called
sovereignty and the limits of
globalization and technology and he's
teaching that at Stanford and that's
happening in the spring of 2019 and I
just want to address some of these
points your current opposition to
globalization is emerging in many
countries in the various forms of
populism restrictive trade policies
protest parties and localism accompanied
by appeals to national interests and
cultural traditions so this idea of
state sovereignty and the way that
markets move an economics move and the
way that nationalistic tendencies can
maybe help in the short term flourish
certain areas in genetic engineering or
artificial intelligence or robotics or
whatever but as well as globalized maybe
in the long run or figure out how
different entities across the the world
can work together as countries to make
sure that there is no robotic warfare AI
warfare or bio warfare etc but this is
very nuanced and multidisciplinary
multivariate so it's very difficult to
actually be able to pinpoint these
individual variables and call them
binary but there's so much nuance which
makes globalization and nationalism very
difficult to to on
stand but you know Peterson's gonna be
breaking it down his perspective on it I
do think a lot in the cosmic perspective
so I look at the moon looking down on
Earth and I do realize that in the long
run we're gonna have to figure out how
to work together on this planet in the
next rock so so anyway this is important
stuff to realize that you know there's
all this conversation that's going on
across all these different topics with
who Peter Thiel is and what he's up to I
think a lot of people don't realize that
necessarily about him and I think it's
important to tune in to who he is at a
deeper level and understand kind of his
mind and the workings of his mind and
why he cares about the Teel fellowship
taking people out of the collegiate
system and into entrepreneurship why he
cares about things like building ocean
colonies are things like globalization
things like Palantir and data fusion
zero to one having those creative
moments and unlocking them building
monopolies etc so thank you everyone
thank you so much for tuning in this has
been some thoughts on Peter Thiel please
go check out more of our work and
support a subscribe comment below we'd
love to hear your thoughts as well join
us on patreon to help us sustain and
continue being able to produce more of
this content we'd greatly appreciate
that and thank you Ron our producer and
director thanks everyone for tuning in
much love peace
[Music]
you
[Music]